Das ist wirklich extrem spannend so ein objekt wurde noch nie absolut noch
Nie in unserem sonnensystem gesichtet es ist extrem schnell kommt wahrscheinlich
Aus den tiefen des alls und durchquert in diesen tagen unser sonnensystem das objekt ist so neu dass es in der astrophysik
Eine kategorie für die bezeichnung gibt woher es kommt was das sensor zähler an dem objekt ist
Und wohin es fliegt jetzt entwicklung science fiction herzlich willkommen
Weltpremiere bei pixum wenn alles korrekt ist was jetzt beobachtet wurde dann haben wir nicht mehr und nicht weniger als den ersten
beobachteten durchflug eines interstellaren objektes durch unser sonnensystem
Absolut bemerkenswert ist schon mal woher es kommt es kommt nämlich von oben
Am 2 september tauchte es senkrecht zu den umlaufbahnen der planeten in unserem sonnensystem
Zwischen sonne und merkur bahn ein die kavitation der sonne lenkte das objekt dann
Unterhalb der sonne in richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der erdumlaufbahn
Am 14 oktober an der erde vorbei flog inzwischen ist das objekt durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder über die planeten
hinaus geschossen worden
ein solches objekt ist absolut nicht
Vorherzusagen und entdeckt werden kann es auch erst wenn es uns schon sehr nahe ist als erster staat assam
achtzehnter oktober 2017 das 1,8 meter
teleskop an stars 1 auf dabei insel maui und dann ergaben die bahn
Berechnungen des objektes sehr schnell dass es nicht von dieser. Welt also nicht von einem anderen planeten hier
Im sonnensystem und überhaupt nicht aus unserem sonnensystem stammte anhand von richtung und geschwindigkeit
Konnte schnell errechnet werden dass es eben senkrecht in unser sonnensystem geflogen war es kam
Aus dem sternbild leier der ursprung liegt nicht unweit des haupt sterns vega wie schwer solche objekte zu entdecken sind
Zeigt dass es nicht entdeckt wurde als es am dichtesten an der erde vorbei flog sondern auch schon sich wieder entfernte
Mit ein grund dürfte die geringe größe mit einem durchmesser von rund 160 metern und die hohe geschwindigkeit
von 26 kilometern pro sekunde also knapp
100.000 kilometer pro stunde wenn die berechnungen jetzt präzisiert werden und sich die bisherigen daten
Bestätigen ist die sensation komplett es ist dann das erste
Interstellare objekt dass wir beim durchflug durch unser sonnensystem entdeckt haben und wir werden es nie wieder sehen während asteroiden ja wie die planeten
Kreise um die sonne ziehen und immer wieder kommt wird das bei diesem
Objekt anders sein es fliegt nach der umlenkung durch die sonne jetzt wieder auf nimmerwiedersehen
in den interstellaren raum bis es wieder auf gestirne trifft dieses umdenken noch trägt es übrigens den namen a
2000 17 uhr 1a steht dabei für assault das wäre aber kein
Interstellare objekt der name muss also noch geändert werden ja wie nur was sind eure ideen schreibt sie die kommentare
Wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht
Den genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasste er auch kein video hier geht es weiter mit
Also, jeden bedrohen die erde jederzeit ja und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran